los decretos que facilitaron el acceso a
las armas son motivos de celebración en
este club de tiro de río de janeiro
desde 2019 mil lugares de este tipo
abrieron sus puertas en brasil decisión
fría
cuando el gobierno actual dio
accesibilidad a las armas también
entendí que tenía que colaborar por eso
hemos ampliado este tema de las armas es
decir con tiendas y compuestos
de stocks desde la elección de jair
bolsonaro se calcula que la adquisición
de armas aumentó en un 300% y las que
ahora circulan son más potentes que las
que eran autorizadas antes
puedes comprar armas hoy en día un civil
puede comprar armas varias veces más
potentes que las utilizadas por la
policía en el grupo específico de los
coleccionistas los tiradores los
privilegios son aún mayores se permite
en algunos casos hasta 60 armas por
persona ante 60 armas por pesos la
explosión de la cantidad de armas
preocupa de cara a las presidenciales
del 2 de octubre hace temer un escenario
similar al asalto al capitolio que
ocurrió en eeuu enero del 2021 tras el
rechazo de los resultados presidenciales
por parte de donald trump
bolsonaro ha emitido dudas sobre la
fiabilidad del sistema electoral
electrónico en brásil
no podemos tener tanto incidentes como
ataques contra candidatos campañas y
mítines algo que ya está ocurriendo en
brasil podemos ver un escenario en el
que el presidente pierda en pugna el
resultado incitando a sus seguidores
muchos de los cuales compraron armas a
amenazar a las instituciones
de la corte suprema a restringir
temporalmente el número de armas y
municiones a las que puedan acceder los
ciudadanos una medida cautelar que no
garantiza que se pueda evitar la
violencia política en el muy polarizado
gigante suramericano